okay good morning so um let us do an
overview of the history of the ancient
Israelites
okay
um from about 1010 the year 1010
BC
until uh
586 um this is what what is referred to
as the first
temple uh period
so remember the nation of Israel is
created by King David and it's a
coalition of different tribes different
cultures different
religions and what makes this nation
possible are two things the first thing
is the Charisma of David the second is
the tremendous literary power and Genius
of the yahs uh the individual who wrote
the first stories of the Bible Adam and
Eve the Patriarchs Moses okay
um and what centers or unifies this
nation
is the first temple in
Jerusalem remember uh to create
centralized Authority David and Solomon
his son Solomon they build a temple
where everyone has to come in order to
make sacrifices to Yahweh okay so the
first temple is the house of Yahweh all
right and at this point we can there are
certain characteristics about this new
religion or this new nation okay and
again um I will have to oversimplify for
the sake of clarity okay so the first
thing I would say about this new
religion is um it's
polytheistic okay it aspires to a
monotheism but it's only aspirational
because the reality is it's a multi it's
a multicultural Coalition and people are
going to believe what their fathers and
their grandfathers
believe okay um they may and so people
at this point have multiple faiths and
so the religion that we refer to say as
uh Judaism is only shared by an El the
elite people okay King David his family
and the priest and maybe other uh people
in the elite okay um second thing
is it is a monarchy
okay and the third thing
is this religion is an open tolerant and
optimistic religion because remember the
Bible it's really the story of two
people Yahweh and David forming an
everlasting friendship that becomes the
basis for the nation of Israel also
remember that in um the yahweh's
understanding of Yahweh Yahweh is a poet
God he's fallible he's sensitive but he
means good he's willing to grow and help
the the Israelites grow as well
and in this religion to show Faith to
Yahweh to um show your Devotion to
Yahweh you must argue with him you must
learn and go grow with him as well okay
so this is a very open confident
generous and
optimistic uh
religion by the time we reach a second
second temple period okay from
539 to 70 uh CE okay 539 BC to 7 uh CE
this is called the second temple
period why because in 586 their Temple
was destroyed by the
Babylonians okay but by the time we
reach this period the Israelites are no
longer referred to as Israelites they're
referred to as
Jews and the Jewish people and the
Israelites they share the Bible but in
terms of culture and values um they're
very different so at this
point the Jewish people have become what
we call hindo
theistic Nea of H
theism is you believe there are Gods but
your God is the best okay your God
Yahweh is superior to all gods and all
the gods are false
Idols they are de
second thing about the second second
second temple period is it's very anti-
monar monarchy okay and so it focus on
the
priesthood and the idea of ritual
religious
ritual so by the second sing Temple
period the focus of power has shifted
from the monarchy the priesthood and in
a minute I'll explain why there was this
change okay the but and the last thing
for our purposes to understand about the
culture is it's become extremely focused
on
Purity okay you can also say it is focus
fanaticism it's a very closed and
conservative culture
now they believe their culture is the
best and they believe it's important not
to inter to mix with other
cultures so for
example Jewish women are explicit
explicitly forbidden to marry foreign
men
okay and then from about 100 CE
onwards there's another
transition to the religion the reason
why is remember in the second temple
period
religious worship is centered around the
second
temple but in 70 CE the Romans destroy
the temple and banish the Jews from
Jerusalem um and so this makes massive
changes to the religion after about 100
CE that carries um it to the present day
the first thing is it becomes fully
monistic they only believe there's only
one God and that's
second
is because there's no more Temple and
you cannot no no longer make any
sacrifices to
Yahweh the center of authority in this
religion called Judaism are the
rabbis and rabbis means teachers okay so
the word for this period is called
rabacal uh
Judaism okay
in other words the Bible becomes the
center of religious worship in Judaism
before it was a temple now it's the
Bible it's the rabbis
who interpret for you what the Bible
means the last thing about this is the
idea of
diaspora dasor just means they are now
spread out all around the world they are
no longer in Jerusalem they're spread
out all around the world and as such um
you will have multiple strands of
Judaism because their religion now has
to interface with local culture and
local
Customs
okay so this is a very broad overview
about over a thousand years of the
history of the de development of Judaism
as you can see
um there are these massive cultural
changes about every 500 years the reason
why is the historical
circumstance of the Israelites and the
Jewish people change over time
remember the Israel the state the nation
of Israel was founded as a historical
accident it was because of the Bron AG
collapse historically the lant was
controlled by a superpower either in
Anatolia or in Egypt or
Mesopotamia but because of the Bron
collaps um the he ties and the ipans
have to retreat from the Levant which
gives space for a localized Empire to
emerge and that's
Israel but over time because the lvon
was so strategically
important Empire started to take over
the lavant as a staging post for an
invasion of Egypt okay so um what would
happen over time is um the Assyrians and
the Babylonians would come and
Conquer uh Israel also because the
nation of Israel was
Multicultural and multi lingual it was
only held together by the personal
Charisma of David So when he died it was
very hard to hold the nation together
and when his son Solon died in 931
BCE the nation of Israel was about into
two kingdoms something called the
Northern Kingdom of Israel and then
Judah the problem with this is the
nation of Israel is centered around the
religion and the religion is centered
around religious rituals in the
temple so and the temple was found in
Jerusalem in Judah so the people in
northern kingdom had to make changes to
religion basically
change uh the sites of religious worship
okay
um in five
86 the Babylonians came and
destroyed um Judah and they burned
the SEC the first temple and the policy
of the Babylonians was
to uh capture the elite and hold them
hostage in
Babylonia and then um send in a foreign
delegation to control the territory okay
and this this is what is called The
Babylon captivity
and while the uh Israelites are there
they're trying to hold on to the memory
of who they are okay there are two
memories that sustain them in this
period the first is the memory of the
greatness of King David how they were
once a United monarchy under the
leadership of David okay so that's
they're very proud of that that's what
sustains them the other thing that
sustains them is the Bible the stories
of the of the Yahweh okay Adam and Eve
the
Patriarchs and because they are so
focused on these memories and because
these memories are written
down um they specialize the Israelites
specialize in intellectual activities
okay so in Babylon and then elsewhere
they become very successful they become
administrators they become teachers they
become
intellectuals okay and they over this
time will also produce their own
literature
as a diaspora people to sustain them and
to unify them okay also at this time
what's important to understand is the
identity as Israelite people becomes
much more concrete and much more locked
in before when they were back in Judea
in the lavant their identity was very
fluid it was very open it was very
Dynamic but now that they are part of
the diaspora they have left Jerusalem
their identity becomes much more
concrete and the analogy would be here
in China we use simplifi Chinese but
guess what when you go to overseas
Chinese communities that diaspora right
in Southeast
Asia um they all use traditional Chinese
characters they hold on to CH Chinese
culture um much more fanatically than in
China does that make sense Okay so
a very
concrete um identity emerges during the
Babylon
captivity also what's important
is they need to if they are to survive
as a people they need to
explain why this is happening to
them during the day theic Kingdom okay
um they were at the height of their
power and the Bible was written at at
the time
and they believe that from now on this
Kingdom of David would last forever and
that's what God promised so why is it
that the northern kingdom and Judah
split and why were they conquered by the
Assyrians and then the Babylonians and
why have they lost their land that God
promised to them and the answer is
because they broke their Covenant with
Yahweh right there's something called a
covenant a contract if
you the Israelite people are loyal to me
meaning you only worship
me then I yah will protect you as my
chosen
people so if
Yahweh has abandoned us it's because of
three reasons okay the first reason is
because um we start to worship foreign
Gods okay that's the first reason second
reason is because say we start to have
Kings and our religion does not allow
Kings because the authority of
Kings um contradicts the authority of
Yahweh okay and the third reason is
because we broke the 10 commandments
because we continue to sin as a
people and the people who argue this are
call the prophets
okay so after the first temple period
being the second temple period uh the
Jewish people adopt a prophetic
tradition the belief
that Jewish people must remain peer to
their love of God if they are to survive
as a
people
okay okay so
um they are in Babylon captivity for um
almost 70 years and then the Persians
conquer the Babylonians and the Persian
Empire is really the first multinational
Empire in human history and their ruler
cus the great he is known for being an
extremely open tolerant and generous
ruler so he releases the Jews from
Babylon and have them return to judism
where they will rebuild their Temple
called the second
temple and this starts the beginning of
the second temple period and the Jews
are so grateful that s the great is
called the
mesiah in their Bible okay Messiah means
the anointed one the one chosen by God
to save the Jewish people and sarit is
the only
Foreigner who is called mesiah in the
Bible s great sponsors both the building
of the second temple as well as
encourage the Jews to start the project
that we now refer to as the
Bible okay and this was led by a priest
uh named erra who was
part um who was in at Babylon but he
returned J Jerusalem to uh rejuvenate
their
religion and to start the Bible okay so
that's a very brief
overview of the history uh of the first
thousand years of
Judaism any questions so far are you
guys clear about this okay so what I
will do now is I'm going to focus
specifically on this period okay when
Cyrus
conquered Babylon and released the Jews
to return to um Jerusalem because this
marks a fundamental shift in the
religion at this point what will happen
is the merger of the Persian religion
with the Israelite religion which
creates a new religion okay now the
religion of the Persians is called
zorm all right and the merge of these
two religions will become the basis of a
new religion that will come to dominate
the world called
Christianity all right okay so to
understand this history I will have to
first talk about the history of
Mesopotamia
okay so as we discussed in class the
history of
motan is one of violent
struggle because there are many violent
uh people in this area and this area is
the center of the world basically it's
where all the trade goes through it's
very wealthy it's very multiethnic and
Multinational so conflict and violence
arises all the time okay so um you have
over here a place called Arabia Arabia
are Nomad nomadic people okay and over
here you have something called the zagal
mountains
up up here is Anatolia which is also
very wealthy and over here are the two
rivers okay the Euphrates and the Tigers
and the city states are built
along the uh two
rivers the PE the do domic people in the
desert of Arabia and the mountains of
Zagros are o opportunistic okay they
will trade with
you but they also will raid you and
steal from you okay they'll possibly be
raiding and trading with the city states
what keeps them in check is these C city
states have
walls okay as well these city states
will fight each
other for
dominance okay because in
mesia the the religion is people must
fight for the honor and Glory of their
Patron God
what keeps the city states from
destroying each other is they believe
that each City
State uh in each city city state in a
temple lives a great God so you can
destroy the enemy's Army in the
battlefield but you can't go and ransack
the city and the temple because that
will incur the Wrath of the God okay so
there are these religious
that keep the system in check and so for
centuries they've been fighting each
other and struggling against each other
and in this process of struggle they
will create many tremendous innovations
that will uh forever change human
history for example they create writing
they they create um many uh forms of
knowledge like mathematics and
astronomy okay so this is considered the
cradle of civilization
this system broke down when a king named
uh
luga zazi okay of a city state called
Uma okay and Uma is always at is always
in with a c State called
leash and look at
zazi he is so ambitious that he's
willing to defy the gods he decides this
is stupid I keep on attacking my enemy
but after Retreat after I win because
I'm afraid of offending their god well
I'm going to test their God I'm going to
go into lagash destroy the temple steal
all their wealth so I can fund other
military um adventures and see if their
God will seek
revenge okay so he's bringing bringing
the taboo he's basically it's basically
like the equivalent of using a nuclear
weapon today okay so he goes to the G
and destroys the gash burns down the
temple steals all their wealth and
nothing happens in fact he becomes even
more successful and he goes around and
starts slowly and slowly
conquering um the city states of mesop
pania of Sumer and he's about to unite
all the entire
region and now the city states are
unified in their hatred of this person
he has defiled their temples he has has
mocked their gods
okay this C an opportunity for another
warlord named
Saron of akad and S of aad is to
determined to destroy luga zazi and
restore the honor and glory of the gods
of
Mesopotamia why is he doing this because
he himself has a legitimacy problem okay
he was a Merc
AR and he was part of the city state of
Kish okay so so he was supposed to be
loyal to the king of Kish but he was an
extremely ambitious and
charismatic Soldier so he did what David
did and he usurped the throne and so now
this creates a legitimacy problem
because remember in this religion um
kings are descended from the gods so now
you by us the throne have offended the
Gods
so Sargon uh his his name means
legitimate King by the way okay
legitimate King which tells us no one
thought he was legitimate
okay he decides that he will create
legitimacy by destroying luga zazi and
he does that okay he destroys LCA zazi
he captures him parades him around and
then kills him to show that he is
favored by the Gods and by doing this
Saron of aad
unifies all of Mesopotamia and he
creates the first world Empire called a
Caden
Empire
okay but also by doing this okay by
creting the first Empire Saron Arad will
now unleash a cycle of
violence
okay and so over time everyone will have
will be forced to become more violent in
order to maintain balance it becomes an
arms raise of fear Terror and
violence and Empires rise and fall all
the time okay again the problem with
this area is you have extremely
aggressive Nations and there are no
natural boundaries to protect you so
it's so even though it's very easy for
you to build an Empire it's also very
easy for you to lose the
Empire okay okay by
600 uh
BCE there are three major powers in this
region okay over here in Anatolia are
people call the
the uh lydian the lydians okay the
lydians over here in mesia are people
call the
Babylonians and over here okay are the
the
medians and the are these are three
superpowers that check and balance each
other out they're powerful but they're
not powerful enough to destroy each
other okay around this time will emerge
a new power center called the
Persians they are led by a great king
named Cyrus the Great okay um here is
considered to be the greatest ruler in
human history a the great saw him as a
role model when a the
great um invaded
Persia and he saw that the two M the
great had been uh desecrated or uh
abandoned he was Furious and he stopped
his campaign to make sure the tomb was
renovated and returned to its former
glory if you go to Iran today you can
still visit the tomb of Cyrus the Great
because throughout history everyone had
a high opinion of him okay even the
Greeks thought he was
fabulous his own people of course loved
him so for the longest time before
alexand great Julius Caesar he was
considered the greatest ruler in human
history
okay so but the problem is because we
don't have access to writing the writing
we have AB we know very little about him
okay here's what we do know about him he
was in charge he was king of a local
people called the Persians who of course
are descended from
theiah okay so they use horse archers in
their Warfare over time he's able to
conquer the
medians King Kroes of the lydians saw
this as an
opportunity to conquer the medians as
well so he attacks but cus the great
defeats him okay so now cus the great is
in charge of two empires what he does
next is revolutionary in Mesopotamia
instead of parading them around like the
the cter kings around and executing them
like s Saron of
aad C great decides to make them
advisors to his court he shows Mercy he
shows clemency he shows
forgiveness and this shocks and alls the
people of
Mesopotamia it shows cus the great is
confident is powerful and is favored by
the gods because he is willing to show
Mercy to his
enemies but not only that what happens
next is really interesting The Babylon
Empire is the last empire in
Mesopotamia okay if such the great wants
to unify Mesopotamia he has to conquer
the Babylonians at this time the
Babylonians have an eternal conflict the
king and the nobility aren't getting
along the king wants to change the
official God of Babylon for Monarch to
sin because the king wants to establish
his own religious Authority so this
creat trous conflict eternally in
Babylon and normally they would go to
Civil War
and normally when they hear that such
the great has conquered the medians and
the lydians then they would think they
have to unify in order to defeat s the
great
but they hear that s the great he's
merciful and he's generous and he's wise
so what they do is the nobility strikes
the deal with s the
great
and cus the great Conquest Babylonia
without doing
anything and in the official history of
s grade he claims that the Congress of
Babylonia was the greatest Conquest was
his greatest Conquest because he did
it through his generosity and his Mercy
as opposed to killing lots and lots of
people
okay and at this time what starts the
Great and the Persians realize is if you
really want to control people you have
to use a policy called divide and
Rule and the idea is this
before these Empires the acadians ass
syrians the Babylonians they believe
that to use violence and fear to control
people but when you do that all you do
is you anger People Unite them and force
them to rebel against
you okay but if you Rec ize that in each
Society there are these natural factions
who are in conf with each other and
you're able to balance these
factions then they're relying on you for
stability okay does that make
sense okay this what we call divide and
Rule so the Persians created not an
Empire but what we call a
federation in other words a federation
is the idea that people choose to be
part of this Federation because it
benefits them okay why does it benefit
them because first of all it brings
peace if there's a conflict you don't
fight each other you go to the Persians
for a conflict resolution okay so it
brings peace second of all it brings
Prosperity through
trade okay so the persons create all
these roads that
enable trade Within than the
Empire and so you're better off actually
trading than you are
fighting
okay and third of all um you're able to
access new knowledge and culture through
this process so the persons were the
first to create a national Imperial
postal system it was very very clever so
all they did was they set up um
checkpoints throughout the Empire and
these these checkpoints they were like
hotels for postmen they had food they
had new clothing they had a place to
sleep these postmen would on their
horses carry mail throughout the Empire
and stop at at these checkpoints to
rest okay so the Persians showed that by
participating in this Empire you could
benefit a lot more more than if you
didn't participate and therefore you
should
participate and so it's an amazing
achievement because remember these
nations were at war with each other
throughout their history and these are
very aggressive people with lots of
religious differences and S the great
and his U descendants were able to
create a system that allowed them to
work together and prosper together and
that's why he is remembered today s
great is remembered today as the the
greatest ruler of all time okay in human
history no one comes
second and also why the Jews refer to
him as Messiah the God God's chosen
God's anointed a man picked by God to
come to save the human people the human
race so with this Federation with this
Empire what's important is the idea of
of administration okay
Administration you need
administrators
who will
be conscientious and
loyal and good people okay because
remember they are working with local
Governors so each region is allow
allowed local autonomy and each Governor
is called satra so they're working with
with the SAT traps to
govern the local area and remember these
stups are allowed maximum autonomy and
freedom to do what they believe the
everyone's allowed to practice their own
religion okay so what the administration
are doing is ensuring divide and Rule
right that there's enough internal
conflict within this region so that
they're all dependent on the empire for
guidance and
Authority these administrators have to
be have to
be um they can't get into like bed with
the SAT trops they can't be corupt
together okay because this the system
will break down so there had to be a
system to keep the administrators loyal
to the Empire and this system is a
religion called
Zionism okay zor
asianism and this is the religion of the
Persian
people and this is the religion of the
Imperial Administration
if you want to be a bureaucrat within
this within this system you have to
believe in Zionism you have to
participate in the rituals and the
rights of
Zionism and what made the system work is
Zionism was at this time 600 BC 500 BC
the best religion in the
world okay so this is a New Concept for
us the best religion in the world we've
discussed the best military in the world
right the best milit in the world has
three characteristics discipline they
fight a lot they have a lot of
experience cohesion they like each other
they get along and devotion they have a
common purpose they have a great leader
that they love okay it turns out
religions can also be measured and there
are certain religions that are better
than other religions based on three
criteria okay these three criteria are
grandness completeness
and
unity okay grandness completeness and
unity and this is not a hard concept so
think of religion as a story and ask
yourself what makes a good story what
makes a story so wonderful you want to
hear it and it's these three things com
grandness it's a big topic Kings and
gods and wars and love okay completeness
there's a beginning and there's an end
and unity there's a
plot things are united okay so if I were
to tell you a story about gilgames who's
a king who fought these gods in a search
for immortality and in the end he
discovers immortality is impossible well
that's a complete unified and Grand
Story and you would want to hear that
story but if I would tell you a story
about a guy named Robert who wants to
get a in school and so he studies all
the time you don't want to hear the
story okay it's not Grand it's very
boring it's not complete there's no
ending it's not really unified because
something really happens okay does that
make sense it's the same with religions
the problem with most
religions is the structure okay so the
typical religion is uh a three Tire
structure so at the center are gods and
gods are the ones who participate in
human Affairs they're the ones
manipulating us but there's also higher
tier that governs the gods as well okay
these are cosmic forces like um fate and
Fortune and then the highest here are
these
invisible laws of the universe that give
it structure okay what is referred to as
um the
immutable and
Unwritten laws of the cost
okay and this is what the Greeks
believed this is what the Romans
believed okay and as you can
see this system it's not complete it's
not unified okay may it may be Grant but
it's not complete or unified it's a very
loose
system zero aism is the first really
Grand complete and unified religion okay
so let's talk let's talk about um zorm
so in the religion they
believe um there is a Creator God okay
called the
aor uh
master and he is the god of creation
he's the God of Light he's the god of
order and he creates a perfect
world
Perfection and within this world we
humans are created
okay but then there is an evil presence
an evil Vil God which comes and corrupts
the
Perfection and uh this evil or
darkness is a match for the Creator God
okay so the world is a perfect balance
of dark and light what tips of balance
is the human race we have free will
therefore we can
choose to fight for goodness or to fight
for Darkness to fight for the truth or
to fight for the lie okay so the two
main uh the the economy is truth and lie
you fight for the truth you're making
the world a better place but you fight
for the lie you are corrupting the world
okay so that's our
choice
eventually a savior a hero will
arise to prepare for the final battle
between dark and Light
in this final battle light will
Triumph once light triumphs a river will
emerge okay River will emerge and
everyone must cross this River everyone
will arise from the dead and everyone
has to cross the river if you have been
good if you if you have fought for the
truth you will cross this River and it
will cleanse you you will feel purified
you will become an eternal Soul who will
live in Paradise forever will return to
Perfection okay but if in your life you
have lived the lie if you have committed
evil if you have done wrong against
other
people then you will
burn in the river and you will be
condemned to hell for the rest of your
life
okay and this is idea what we call es
eschatology
esoy okay so this is a hard word esy but
I I need you guys remember it because
it's a very important word eschatology
means an understanding of how the world
ends and Zionism is a first
eschatological religion it has an
ending a final battle good versus evil
where everyone will be judged
okay and so now we can understand why
the Persian system works because if you
are to be an administrator if you are to
work for the Empire you and you believe
in jism then you have a duty to fight
for the truth okay we're here at most
for 60 80
years and what we do in the 6080 years
will will be will decide how we live our
lives for all eternity okay we either
live in Paradise or we will burn in hell
depending on how we perform these 60 to
80 years so the Persians are under
tremendous pressure to be a good person
this is radical in the history of
humanity okay so remember the mesop
Mesopotamians believe you are good if
you achieve right how do you know you're
good because you've achieved a lot and
by achieving a lot you show that Gods
favor
you and Egyptians believed in
status and others believed and just good
luck okay but the Persians believe you
have to be a good person you have to
show generosity compassion and mercy to
others as as exemplified by the life and
works and words of Cyrus the
Great okay so that's
Zionism and this is so powerful that it
will be adopted into Judaism
and eventually become the basis for
Christianity okay but this is where it
started
Zionism any questions so far before I
continue are you guys clear about what's
happening okay you know that's a good
question if this is the best religion
what what are the worst ones okay uh
you're right there's really no Bad
Religion okay um but the most common
religion is folklor religions right so
so you live in a village and you believe
in a local God okay does that make
sense um and so when I say it's best
what I mean is intellectually it's the
best it's it's it's a religion that can
attract the best and the brightest do
you understand it's it's a religion
where
um um um if you are a very intelligent
person you are attracted to this
religion okay does that make sense but
if you are just a normal person you're
just going to believe what your father
and your grandfather
believed okay so think of this religion
almost as the equivalent of the
confusion Classics in
China how do you show cultivation in
China by reading the confusion classics
and if you want to become a scholar
official you have to memorize the
confusion Classics right the same
concept here where zor aism um you have
to believe in this religion if you want
to become an administrator and the
problem with this religion that makes it
hard for people to understand is it's
very
abstract okay that's the main failing of
this religion it's very abstract it's
very intellectual and that's why a lot
of people don't really see this as a
religion and more as a philosophy
and what's also important important for
us to understand is the abstraction is
what makes this religion appealing right
because the Persians are trying to
attract the best and brightest for for
for their
Administration so they don't want a
popular religion they're not trying to
they're not they're not trying to
promote their religion okay they're
trying to use their religion to filter
out uh the best and the
brightest okay does that make sense okay
so so you're right it's I can't say this
is the best religion but it's the
religion that is the most intellectual
and which will attract uh the
administrators in the Persian Empire and
that's why it's
effective okay great question okay any
more
questions yes
like
expain okay so of completeness is esy
okay an ending because most religions
don't actually have an
ending they don't have they're not like
okay this is when the world
ends okay so for example uh um King
David the Bible right it's telling us
that King David is really the end of
history and from now on on we will live
forever in this davidic Kingdom okay
this is the best we can
do but it's not saying okay King David
um we will eventually reach a point when
the world ends and when God returns to
the Earth no religion is doing that
before zor rism
okay does that make sense okay so think
of completeness as a circle right
because if you look at Zur aism they say
this is a Perfection right but now
there's
corruption so the story ends when
corruption ends and we we return to
Perfection so the circle closes okay
does that make sense the same with the
Bible where we start out in the Garden
of Eden and then we are corrupted and we
are forced out of the Garden of Eden
right but Noah does it say we will
return to the Garden of
Eden and but when we reach Christianity
that's what will happen Jesus will proom
will Jesus is promise of the return to
the Garden of Eden okay so now the
circle closes does that make sense any
more
questions okay um all right let's
continue
so we have this religion Zionism and
eventually uh the Jews were adopted into
their own religion okay and we have C
the great who is this wise generous and
merciful leader okay but he he is this
way because he is
strategic okay he's
strategic so when he allows the Jews to
return to Jerusalem he's doing so for
strategic purposes okay he's not doing
it because he feels sorry for the Jews
he's doing it because there's a certain
strategic purpose in allow them to
return to Jerusalem and the reason why
is Jerusalem the lant as we discussed it
is very important geographically it
marks access into Egypt which is what s
the great eventually wants to conquer
because Egypt is the wealthiest nation
in the world at this time so he needs to
bring stability to the lant and in the
in the Persian worldview what creates
stability is the balancing of forces
within the local area Okay so he needs
to create conf in the Levant at this
point in the
Levant
um there are still Israelites living
there and they are now called this um
the
Samaritans okay um and then you have the
Jews okay the Jews is a Persian word it
means people who live in the province of
Judea which is a Persian Province okay
so they're called Jew Jews now uh and
not Israelites Israelites are now called
Samaritans
these come from the same people okay but
the difference is this the Israelites
who stay have adapted to new
circumstances and so what this means is
they still practice their religion but
they've also intermarried with wom of
different faiths so now it's common for
a household to practice many different
faiths whereas the Jews in Babylon
they're more fanatical they believe it's
important to practice only one faith
so when pyus the Great sends the Jews
back to the Levant this immediately
creates conflict between the Samaritans
who believe they are the true
descendants of the Israelites and the
Jews who believe they are the true
descendants of the Israelites so this
creates religious conflict in the Levant
which means the Persians are able to
become the
Arbiter okay and this creates Divine and
Rule
now what's important for us to
understand
is the Jews who return to the Samaritans
are only the most fanatical Jews okay
there only minority of people the rest
of the Jews are perfectly happy in
Mesopotamia they have very successful
careers as administrators as
intellectuals as teachers they're happy
where where they
are okay so it's only the most religious
uh extremists who return and there are a
minority
so Samaritans are in the majority so the
perch support the Jews who've returned
in trying to create Purity okay so the
Jews argue for
Purity uh the Samaritans argue for
tolerance and so this is a power
struggle a a religious power
struggle in 44 3 BC around then a priest
a Jewish priest named Ezra he returns to
Jerusalem and he's determined to win
this war okay so there are certain
things he does the first thing he
does that is extremely controversial is
he
announces if you are a Jewish man you
must
divorce a foreign woman if you're
married to a foreign woman meaning a
woman who doesn't share our faith then
you must divorce her in order to
maintain the purity of our
people okay he also announces that from
now on it is mandatory for Jewish men to
observe religious rituals to go to the
temple and make your sacrifice okay so
he's trying to stop his
Purity but his main contribution which
is the most important is he wants to
UNIF
ify the Jewish PE people into
one um faction okay so let me explain
why this is important so as we discuss
there are
multiple Bibles out there
okay and so there's at least four
different schools or four different
strands there is the House of David
school called the yahs right the the
yahs or
J remember this is um this is the idea
of the Yahweh that Yahweh he is a
fallible good meaning well-meaning
poet
okay but the main point of the Yahweh
the the yah is God has chosen David to
be the legitimate ruler of Israel God
has also ordained David to build the
temple where God will reside Okay so is
to legitimize the authority of David and
to make people understand the central
authority of this religion is the temple
in Jerusalem but as we discussed
eventually the northern kingdom will
break away from
Judah but when once you break away you
can't access Jerusalem anymore so now
you have to have other sites where you
can practice your religious rituals okay
but you do that you have to change the
Yahweh manuscript and so they do that
and create uh new mythologies this is
what What's called the E manuscript okay
for
elohist elois is is just a different
word for God right does that make sense
so so you have two competing Bibles at
the same time you have the Priestly
manuals okay so remember um Judaism at
this point it is a religion focus on
ritual like most religions so you need
uals in order to tell you why you're
doing these rituals and how you should
do these rituals they to be very precise
they to be effective
okay at the same time as the northern
kingdom fell as Judah was conquered by
the Babylonians as as the Jews are
forced into
captivity you have to explain why this
is happening okay and while this is
happening most people choose to not
follow religion anymore okay they adopt
a new religion or they move somewhere
else okay but the religious Fanatics
have to explain why this is happening
and the explanation is because the
Israelites continue to disobey God and
this faction uh which is basically
looking at Jewish history explaining
what this is happening is call the
deuteronomist okay the D School the
deuteronomist
okay so these are four major factions
okay you understand and these are four
different Bibles now wants to do is put
all these four Bibles
together to create the impression of a
unified religion and a unified people
and the way he does that which is very
interesting is he basically just takes
different parts from each of these books
and puts them together okay and now this
is the
Bible and that's why if you actually
read the Bible you'll find it completely
unreadable okay but he also makes
changes to the Bible which is very
important remember before the most
important person was David okay because
he's really a founder of the nation of
Israel he's a founder of religion now
the most important person is
Moses because Moses is a priest he is
the one who was given the laws by
Yahweh okay so there are other CH
changes as well but this is the most
important okay there are other changes
that will come over time as Zoran aism
merges into Judaism okay so there are
three major changes um the first is the
idea of
eschatology okay meaning there will be
an end point to history and the end
point of history is when the entire
world when all the empires of the world
because they defy God converge against
the nation of Israel in one final
battle okay and in this battle of course
Israel will win and this will create
Eternal peace in the world because God
has chosen Israel as his people second
big idea
is um good versus
evil okay before the religion of Judaism
was very personal good and evil was in
you but now it's there is actually good
and evil okay Israel stands for good
these other nations these other Empires
like the Babylonians the Greeks the
Romans they represent
evil okay and the third change and which
is the most important is there will be a
hero who will come to lead the nation of
Israel against all its enemies and he is
called the Messiah the Son of Man Okay
the son of
man and he will come from the House of
David as written in the Bible okay and
why is this important
because the Christians believe the
Messiah is
Jesus okay so the Christians basically
take all this this merger of zinis with
Judaism and their claim is the Messiah
is
Jesus okay and this creates Christianity
which we will discuss next
class all
right okay any questions so
far are you guys clear about all this
y excuse
me
okay yeah okay thanks thank you okay
okay all right so so let let me explain
what's happening okay so um remember the
Babylon once the Babylonians in 586 they
take over Jerusalem they burn a temple
to destroy the religion of the Jews and
they take the
elite about a few thousand people they
move them to uh Babylonia okay and but
what's who's left behind are a majority
the majority of Israelites okay but now
they have to adopt to a new
Elite and so they preserve their
religion but they they also adopt the
religion of the elite who are the
Babylonians you also have um Israelites
who go off to Egypt okay so so now you
create something called a diaspora
they're either in Babylon or they're in
Egypt but the majority are still at home
in Judea and in this time because these
are just ordinary people they will adopt
many faiths it's very common back then
for a person to have like multiple
faiths okay the faith of your father the
faith of your mother the faith of your
wife okay the faith of your neighbor
okay because this is how people got
along right if you said that my God is
better than your God you will piss off
your neighbor you will piss off your
colleague why why would you do that so
it's very common back then for people to
have multiple Faith a faith you might
practice at home a faith you might share
with your friends a faith you might have
to share with your king okay does that
make sense okay so these are extremely
multi- uh religious people
as we discussed when the Jews are when
when the Israelites are forced to go to
Babylon they are forced to have a more
fanatical religion in order to maintain
their
identity right it's like how do you
separate yourself from these other
people because if you don't do that what
happens is you become assimilated right
you lose what it means to be Israelite
and quite honestly most people chose to
be assimilated because that was the
easiest thing to do but there's a
fanatical minority mainly priests who
were determined to keep alive their
religion because only by keeping alive
the religion could they keep alive
Yahweh could they keep alive Israel okay
so when these Jews were allowed to
return to Judea they were
horrified by the corruption and Purity
they
saw right they were like where were in
Babylon and for 70 years we fought hard
to save our religion to maintain the
purity of our religion they go back and
they see their people the Samaritans now
adopt foreign gods and they were like
this is why we fail as a
people this is why Yahweh punished us
because we refused to be loyal so what
so they thinking is like I would rather
all these people go away
then have them stay around you
understand we don't want to get a law we
want to maintain the purity of our
religion because that's the only way to
save our
people
okay and that's why they say hey if
you're want to stay you have to divorce
your wife who is a foreigner if you if
you don't do if you don't want to do so
go away man the pran Empire is huge go
somewhere else but Jerusalem is only the
land of the pure
okay does that make
sense so U you know I know this is
controversial idea but it's really only
the extremists who keep the religion
alive right this this is true for all
religions okay does that make sense it's
only people who are most willing to die
for the religion uh that keeps the
religion alive if everyone's willing to
compromise the religion dies very
quickly okay and the Jewish religion
Judaism is able to um stay alive for
3,000 years
because there are lots of people in the
religion a minority but still a lot a
lot of people who are willing to die for
the religion this something we'll
discuss later on this semester okay so
thanks for the question any more
questions okay so next class we will
discuss the rise of Christianity okay
Jesus basically